à compter de ce lundi les diabétiques
des ivelines vont recevoir donc un
courrier de la CPAM des Yvelines pour
leur proposer d'adhérer gratuitement à
sopia sopia ce dispositif
d'accompagnement dans l'agglomération
les villes de trappe et de la verrière
sont les communes les plus concernées
par cette maladie chronique explication
Catherine zulato et LOD moine à compé de
ce lundi les diabétiques des ivelines
vont recevoir un courrier de leur caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie les
incitants à s'inscrire au programme
sopia un programme d'accompagnement
gratuit basé sur le volontariat ils vont
bénéficier d'un accompagnement de la
part de la changeche maladie un
accompagnement à distance à la fois par
le biais d'envoi de documents de livret
de fiche conseil mais également un
accompagnement téléphonique relayé par
nos infirmières conseil ils pourront
ainsi obtenir des conseils alimentaires
des conseils en matière d'exercice
physique et même un rappel sur le suivi
de leurs rendez-vous médicaux André
Clébert est président de la Maison du
diabète des ivelines il est donc bien
informé et pourtant ce service pourrait
lui être bien utile surtout dans les
moments de découragement de temps en
temps c'est difficile de de dire il faut
que j'aille voir le cardiologue il faut
que j'aille voir le flébologue il faut
que ça devienne des
réflexes et avant que ça devienne des
réflexes quand on fait beaucoup d'autres
choses euh ben on peut oublier et quand
on fait quand on reste seul avec son
diabète alors là c'est encore plus
triste parce qu'on a pas le courage d'y
aller sopia existe en France depuis 2008
il a déjà été mis en place dans 19
départements et le constat et le suivant
les patients prennent mieux en charge
leur maladie dans les Yvelines plus de
35000 personnes vont recevoir ce
courrier à 50 ans en Yveline 6000
diabétiques sont concernés à noter que
les enfants n'entrent pas dans le cadre
du
dispositif et pour continuer à évoquer
donc ce dossier ce nouveau dispositif je
reçois Marion Bouri bonsoir vous êtes la
responsable du département des services
en santé de la CPM la Caisse Primaire
d'Assurance Maladie dans le département
des ivelines on l'a entendu ce
dispositif sopia existe déjà en France
ça a donné de bons résultats oui
effectivement le dispositif sopia a été
mis en place dans déjà 19 départements
en France il y a une enquête une
évaluation qui a été menée suite à la
mise en place de dispositifs et on
constate effectivement une meilleure
observance des recommandations et des
prescriptions médicales par les
personnes diabétiques on peut tout de
même aussi s'intéresser un petit peu aux
chiffres qui ont été donnés dans ce
reportage et cette situation trappe la
verrière sur 550S en Eveline par exemple
ce sont les communes où il y a le plus
de personne la population est le plus
fortement touchée par des cas de de
diabète ça s'explique comment alors
comment pour l'instant je pense qu'on a
pas forcément mené les études
suffisamment pointu pour pouvoir dire
c'est pas forcément un hasard c'est pas
forcément hasard alors c'est vrai que
souvent on fait un lien quand même entre
la
nutrition la catégorie
socio-professionnelle et l'apparition du
diabète c'est vrai que ce qu'on constate
c'est que sur la communaité
d'agglomération de 50 ans en iveline sur
les communes de trappe et de laavrière
on a une prévalence du diabète qui est
quasiment le double de la prévalence sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau
départemental 3,5 % sur la seule ville
de trapppe c'est 5,4 % par exemple voilà
ou sur la ville de La Verrière on
atteint les 9,3 % également sur les
personnes de entre 40 et 59 ans voilà
pour dire c'est un véritable problème
aujourd'hui qui est rencontré par une
partie de la population sur ces
communesl plus principalement le
dispositif qui est mis en place alors
est ouvert au au diabétiques majeurs
mais pas aux enfants pas au plus
jeunesou pas au plus jeunes non
effectivement le le dispositif c'est un
dispositif d'accompagnement et donc il
nécessite une adhésion pleine et entière
de la part de la personne diabétique et
donc effectivement ça nécessite que
cette personne soit soit majeure que
vont trouver les malades justement avec
ce nouveau dispositif quelense ce
nouveau dispositif les malades vont
trouver un accompagnement au quotidien
avec le dispositif Sofia on est vraiment
dans l'aide à l'observance médical on
est vraiment
pour donner des des petits conseils au
quotidien pour accompagner aussi dans
les prescriptions qui sont faites par
les professionnels de santé donc on est
là pas pour remplacer l'action du
professionnel de santé mais bien pour
l'accentuer et pour aller dans dans le
même sens donc on est là sur une
complémentarité d'action avec les
professionnels de santé et donc c'est
vraiment un dispositif qui est
mobilisable par la personne diabétique
donc il y a un numéro verre que la
personne peut appeler quand elle le
souhaite et il y a également donc des
appels sortants qui sont organisés donc
la personne diabétique qui adhère au
dispositif pourra recevoir des appels de
la part d'infirmier qui pourront voilà
de temps en temps effectivement faire un
point sur l'observance des
recommandations est-ce que la personne
effectivement a bien fait c'est donc son
suivi chez chez les médecin parce que ça
ça arrive souvent justement des
personnes qui sont diagnostiquées comme
ayant le le diabète qui ensuite ne font
pas pas forcément très bien traitement
le suivi en tout cas oui c'est vrai
qu'il y a énormément de de suivi à faire
quand on est diabétique c'est c'est très
lourd donc il faut bien penser faire ses
prises de sang à faire ses hémoglobines
gliqué et cetera donc tant que
finalement on l'a pas intégré dans sa
vie quotidienne ça devient presqueun
charge et l'idée justement c'est
d'arriver à à continuer à vivre
normalement mais avec son diabète et
donc de donner tous les petits conseils
qui permettent au quotidien d'intégrer
le diabète dans sa vie quotidienne et de
pas modifier trop aussi ses habitudes
enfin modifier ces habitudes oui mais
mais effectivement continuer à vivre
normalement avec son diabète et l'idée
aussi c'est de soulager peut-être un
petit peu les médecins qui souvent sont
débordés peut-être par ce genre d'appel
de personnes qui sont un peu perdu dans
leur suivi dans leur traitement je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est
effectivement agir en complémentarité
puisque comprendre son diabète ça
demande quand même voilà un certain
temps et c'est en tout cas un temps
aujourd'hui qu'on on peut constater que
pour les médecins généralistes
effectivement ça prend énormément de
temps et donc on est là aussi ben on est
mobilisable du coup quand la personne le
souhaite donc avec ce ce numéro vert qui
est qui est mobilisable très très très
rapidement euh et puis du coup forcément
euh avec vraiment on agit aussi en
fonction du besoin de la personne et il
y a une évolution aussi dans dans les
actions qu'on peut mener avec les les
adhérents mais vous nous le dites il
faut être volontaire c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que ça s'adresse aux personnes
qui sont majeures et pas pas au plus
jeunes il faut vraiment avoir envie de
le faire de le suivre pourquoi ne pas le
rendre
obligatoire parce que pour rendre
quelqu'un Act vous voulez pas que ce
soit contraignant non il y a il y a
effectivement aucune contrainte et puis
pour que ce soit efficace il faut aussi
que les personnes euh bah soit acteur et
donc effectivement montre une volonté
parce que si on rend les choses
obligatoires forcément l'impact pour
nous je pense qu'il sera beaucoup moins
bon et en terme d'évaluation je pense
qu'on ressentira aussi le fait que les
gens bah comme c'est une contrainte
voilà l'obligation on sait que dans ce
dans ce type de de de d'affection et
comme c'est sur du long terme si on est
dans la contrainte on aura forcément une
efficacité beaucoup moindre 5965 € vous
me dites si je me trompe c'est le
remboursement annuel moyen des en soins
d'une personne pour un diabète
l'objectif en France et l'objectif on
l'imagine aussi c'est de réduire ce coût
pour la CPN oui forcément plus la prise
en charge sera faite tô et dans une de
meilleur qualité et forcément plus aussi
on arrivera à maîtriser le coût
puisqueen fait le diabète c'est une
maladie insidieuse plus on avance dans
le temps avec cette maladie et plus les
complications peuvent apparaître donc
plus est prise tôt plus les
comportements les bons comportements
sont mis en place de bonheur et moins du
coup on ira vers des complications et
donc forcément avec une prise en charge
moins lourde et là c'est une structure
qui s'installe durablement vous êtes en
phase de test sur le département non non
donc euh le dispositif a été testé sur
19 départements et là aujourd'hui il est
généralisé sur toute la France combien
ça va coûter concrètement on parlait de
chiffres tout à l'heure voilà donc
combien ça va coûter al par Ch alors
aujourd'hui on atteint un coût par
adhérant de 115 € et l'objectif donc on
a donc à terme une cible d'un million de
personnes et on souhaite donc du coup c
enfin forcément le volume diminuera
aussi le coût de de cette prestation et
donc l'objectif cible c'est d'atteindre
un coût de 70 € par patient diabétique
donc si on met ça en relation par
rapport à au coût de la prise en charge
qui est de presque 6000 VO presque 6000
€ du coup on voit que cet investissement
pour nous il est il est vraiment on a
tout intérêt en tout cas à agir dans ce
sens-là ça veut dire que ce sera étendu
aussi à d'autres maladies chroniques
peut-être oui effectivement l'idée c'est
de aujourd'hui on parle de de diabète
mais effectivement il y a d'autres
pathologies chroniques qui pourraient
permettre ce type d'accompagnement et
donc aujourd'hui on travaille justement
à généraliser ce type de dispositif sur
d'utes d'autres pathologies merci Marion
B nous parler donc de ce dispositif de
la CPM le dispositif sopia on vous
renvoie une fois de plus vers notre site
Internet pour revoir toutes les
informations revoir le reportage qui
était aussi consacré au lancement
c'était vendredi dernier merci à vous
tout autre sujet à présent le monde des
dinosaures c'est à la base de loisirs de
50 ans en Eveline pour le plaisir
évidemment des enfants qui découvrent à
travers un quiz l'univers des diplodocus
et autres tyrannosaures et puis juste
après nouvelle édition du 78 sport
rendez-vous hebdomadaire pour un point
complet sur laactu
sportive les dinosaures s'installent à
la base de loisirs de saintquenttin en
Eveline rissement animaux en taille
réelle espèces articulé au total 20
animations de tricératops 10ocus et
autres mamouth les enfants forcément
passionnés par ces animaux
préhistoriques ont chacun leurs préféren
concernant les activités
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
proposées le
film un monsieur en fait il va sur une
île des
dinosaures attention derrièrei j'ai eu
dinosaure parce
que
bah c'est
passionnant
et il y en a qui font peur et il y en a
qui sont drôles j'ai
préféré la télé et aussi les C ici et
là-bas d'accord beaucoup aimer ça j'ai
plein de livres
de de de dinosaures sous le chapitau les
enfants de 6 à 12 ans découvrent
l'exposition et répondent au quiz
distribués à l'entrée 20 questions sur
l'univers des dinosaures où vivait-il
que mangeait-il quand ont-ils disparu
l'exposition se veut éducative on trouve
toutes les réponses sur les panneaux au
cours de la visite mais bon il faut
quand même lire donc c'est pour les
enfants c'est assez éducatif c'est
pédagogique et bon voilà fa vraiment
chercher tout ça une fois le quiz
corrigé les enfants repartent avec un
petit diplôme en souvenir de
l'exposition